China has starred in what has been the greatest
economic revolution in the history of mankind.
However, in spite of this, in 2017, both Moody's
and Standard and Poor's, 2 of the 3 main rating
agencies, reduced the Chinese debt’s rating.
For its part, the International Monetary Fund
itself has been issuing warnings on this for
months...
Yes, the Chinese economy is growing strongly,
but... that doesn’t mean that everything
is going well... not at all.
In recent years, - as we’ve already discussed
in a video I will leave at the end with a
description – China's economy has seen one
parameter soar exponentially: corporate debt.
And this isn’t small news…
Chinese corporate debt accounts for almost
170% of China's GDP.
To give you an idea of what this means, we
could say that this 170% GDP level is one
of the highest on the planet... and is, for
example, twice that of the United States.
But...
some of you may be wondering... if the Chinese
economy seems to be doing so well...
How did its companies accumulate such a huge
debt?
Well... the truth is that in recent years
Chinese companies have gone on a kind of spending
spree all over the world...
they have bought everything...
foreign companies, ports, airports, mines,
railways... even soccer teams.
The Chinese "invasion" seemed unstoppable...
and that’s precisely what caused so many
countries to develop an aggressive discourse
against this kind of occupation...
And, not only that, as the Chinese have begun
investing in the poorest countries – as
in Africa – many analysts, journalists and
activists have accused Beijing of practicing
a kind of colonialism.
And, beware, this phenomenon is quite widespread:
companies, investors, entrepreneurs, government
institutions...
it doesn’t matter...
In recent years the obsession to get money
out of China has been shared, practically,
by every person in the Chinese economy.
Surely some of you are thinking...
Chinese people buying all kinds of things
all over the world?
People in Beijing must be rubbing their hands
together...
Well... the truth is that no, nothing could
be further from the truth, in fact throughout
the last year Xi Jinping’s government has
launched many measures to stop this process...
One moment--the Beijing government wants to
stop this Chinese purchase wave?
Don’t they want to take over the world?
Well... it's not that they don’t want to...
but they have their reasons.
Listen up.
(THE OTHER FACE OF CHINESE INVESTMENT)
Imagine we want to invest abroad.
As you can imagine, we can do it in many different
ways:
For example, we can buy debt from a foreign
government, from a foreign company, from a
foreign bank; we can also buy shares in another
country’s stock market...
But we can also carry out what is known as
Foreign Direct Investment... that is... buy
a local company, open a store, a factory,
a workshop, etc., etcetera.
In other words, invest in a real asset in
the field.
Well, obviously a direct foreign investment...
implies a greater degree of complexity and
greater risk, which is why it’s expected
to generate greater profitability.
Of course, if it weren’t, there would be
no incentive to implement them... after all,
it’s infinitely easier to buy financial
assets while sitting in front of a computer
at the office or, even, at home.
Well... the fact is that, paradoxically...
as this type of investment has grown in recent
years, its profitability has plummeted...
According to China's state currency administration,
the rate of return, this type of investment’s
profitability, dropped to barely 0.4% in 2016....
All despite the fact that almost every stock
market was skyrocketing.
Therefore, in spite of the colonialism accusations...
the truth is that many of the Chinese investment
projects are working so badly that they’re
more of a headache than the business of
the century.
Now, you may be thinking... but Simon...
Where’s the problem?...
Just making too little money?
Well, dear viewers…
according to what we learned on corporate
debt...
Yes, it is.
A large part of this huge international expansion
was financed with debt... debt that, of course,
must be repaid with interest... and if the
investments failed or didn’t generate the
expected returns...
it could generate a huge solvency problem...
which would obviously seriously affect the
Chinese financial system, which belongs fundamentally
to the government.
Let’s take, for example, the Sinohydro and
China Railway Engineering Corporation case,
two engineering and construction companies
owned by the Chinese government.
See, in 2007, they reached a huge agreement
with the Congolese government.
In exchange for a concession to exploit copper,
they committed to investing 9 billion dollars
in the African country, 3 billion in the mine
and 6 billion in infrastructure.
Two government-owned companies that had nothing
to do with mining and were entirely financed
by a Chinese government-owned bank.
Well, do you know what has happened since
then?
These Chinese companies have already invested
more than 2 billion dollars and so far everything
has been a problem...
the price of copper fell, the reserves weren’t
as big as expected, the logistical costs were
very high...
Because they hadn’t even guaranteed their
power supply...
And of course, all that meant many more costs
and many delays.
Only 9 years later, in 2016, they were able
to start extracting copper... in much lower
quantities than expected...
So, whatever the future holds, the reality
is that during the last decade this agreement...
was a big headache... and a great source of
losses.
And don’t think that this project was an
exception, the truth is that in recent years,
Chinese companies, government-owned and private
companies, alike, have gotten into serious
debt buying all kinds of assets without caring
about the price.
But that’s not all.
In addition, all these investments mean capital
leaving the country...
at such a high rate that between 2011 and
the beginning of 2017, Chinese currency reserves
plummeted by a trillion dollars...
And that, my friends, is a lot, a lot of money.
And it’s something that goes in the opposite
direction of what Beijing wants, which in
recent years tried to strengthen the Yuan.
Now...
Why are Chinese investors so eager to get
money out of the country?
And, why do they seem so surprisingly bad
when it comes to investing abroad?
Listen up.
(THE BAD INCENTIVES)
Folks, the fact that Chinese investors seem
so incompetent when it comes to investing
abroad is a matter of incentives and bureaucracy.
See... the main priority for the Chinese who
managed to make money, is to transfer part
of their assets abroad...
Why?
Well... it’s fundamentally a matter of legal
safety.
Allow me to explain: As you know China is
a dictatorship... and that means that if tomorrow
you have a problem with political power...
your money could disappear... and not only
that... as in any dictatorship...
there are many restrictions... because if
things go wrong, what could be better than
having part of your patrimony protected in
other countries?
Seems sensible, right?
I’d certainly do it.
Wouldn’t you?.
Well, that’s one of the explanations for
why so many Chinese businessmen wanted to
invest their money as quickly as possible,
even if that meant paying a premium, a surcharge...
But that isn’t the only reason.
Additionally, in recent years, since 2008,
the Chinese government promoted easy and cheap
credit as a mechanism to boost the economy...
And, of course, when you can get into debt
under such favorable conditions...
you won’t be as demanding when selecting
which projects to invest in.
Yes, this is one of the big problems with
expansive monetary policies.
They encourage bad investments that later...
are hard to pay off.
But... just a moment...
The entities most responsible for the huge
slab of corporate debt that we’ve talked
about… have been not private companies...
but state owned ones.
And this... though surprising, also has a
lot to do with incentives…
See, investing outside of the country in large
amounts meant that managers could puff up
their chests before the Beijing government
due to the huge growth that their companies
had achieved.
On the other hand it meant many of these managers
could move to another country and charge a
lot of money.
Let's say that their interests are different
from those of their companies.
And, of course, if business was done in countries
as complicated as Africa...
it was also easier to take a slice, set out
their hand, get a commission.
In addition, Chinese state-owned companies
have huge bureaucratic structures... which
makes decision-making and adapting to any
changes that may occur very, very slow.
Yes, state-owned companies tend to be much
more inefficient.
Well... that’s what Xi Jinping wants to
face... while trying to consolidate his power.
(THE DANGEROUS GAME)
An important point: this huge shopping maelstrom
-which is often done without too much thought-
also happened in Japan in the 80s, that is,
before the great crisis of the early 90s.
And in Beijing they’re terrified that something
similar will happen to them...
So, what do you think they did?
Well... they introduced a lot of restrictions
on foreign investments...
in such a way... that now the Chinese government
can veto corporate operations abroad for Chinese
companies....
even if they are carried out by private companies.
And this... has a double intention because
in addition to cooling the foreign investment
process... it also strongly reinforces Xi
Jinping’s political power.
Let's say that with this excuse, the Chinese
government has taken an enormous mechanism
out of its sleeve to reward friends and punish
the less loyal.
In addition, with the excuse of increasing
control...
Beijing is also promoting the merging of government-owned
companies – which until now worked autonomously
– to create huge corporations....
that give Beijing even more power.
Of course, all these actions...
can weigh on the growth of Chinese companies,
decrease competition and increase the bureaucracy
and inefficiency with which the Chinese public
sector operates.
But, yes, Xi Jinping will get even more power.
China has many strengths, but this is one
of its great weaknesses.
Even so, Chinese savings are so high... that
it seems difficult to reproduce a financial
crisis like the one Japan experienced...
but the risk still exists.
Now it’s your turn.
Do you think that Xi Jinping's ambition will
end up hurting China?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as the survey.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Please check out our friends at the Reconsider
Media Podcast - they provided the vocals in
this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.